hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
it is unfinished work the pasta is
Blaise Pascal is going to very
consistently draw a distinction between
two different conceptions or if you like
two different fundamental compartments
towards God that is the divine and he of
course is by the time he writes this a
practicing Christian so it is the
traditional god of monotheism that he
has in mind what is the distinction it's
between the God that is understood by
the philosophers and not the atheists or
skeptic philosophers there's plenty of
them out there but but philosophers that
actually do think that God exists and
that we can have some rational knowledge
of God and then the God of the faithful
practicing religious person who could be
Christian although at one point he says
that you know genuine Judaism and
Christianity are going to overlap to
some extent so there's some prospect for
that there we don't need to go into that
at this point the fundamental
contradiction is between we could say
the God of faith and the God of
philosophy notice I don't say the God of
faith and the god of reason because
reason is not something that is solely
on the side of philosophy as against
religion or theology or faith whatever
it is that you set up as its other
Paschal is not
Tertullian he is not merely what we call
a fee deist who says that reason is
useless and that faith supplies
everything instead his position is a bit
more complex let's begin in thinking
about this by looking at what he says
about Descartes because I think this is
quite helpful for putting things into
context the cart is one of Pascal's
contemporaries and he says I cannot
forgive Descartes in all his philosophy
he would have been quite willing to
dispense with God to not have God in the
picture at all
but he had to make him that is God give
a Philip a little push to set the world
in motion beyond this he has no further
need of God and I think that that's you
know a little bit of a
oversimplification of the Cartesian
doctrine but on the large it's really a
fair accusation that God shows up in the
Cartesian system early on basically to
give him a way out of the methodological
doubt that he uses to get everything
started and to provide a way to get all
of the world of extension which is what
Descartes is really really interested in
as a scientist out there and to allow a
connection between the world of thought
and the world of extension that can be
certain or at least probable after that
Descartes really doesn't use God or even
refer much to God he certainly if he
does have religious beliefs is much more
of a dais t' than a traditional
christian so this is a good example of
what Paschal has in mind when he looks
at the god of the philosophers and again
remember these are not all philosophers
this is a particular set in his own time
and we can find similar people today
they view God as this being that can be
known putting faith aside putting
religious commitments or revelations
aside can be known through reason and
this provides them with a great optimism
about our human nature and it's perfect
ability about the capacity that we have
to purify religion if we want to have it
around any of its dross superstition
silliness any of those sorts of things
so what sort of forms is this going to
take
in part what Pascal will call
metaphysical proofs of God's existence
these are the things that are familiar
to any of us by going and taking a
philosophy religion class or even an
intro class or reading online about the
area of philosophy of religion the
ontological the cosmological the design
we can go on and on with various
arguments these are all attempts to say
that we have some rational grounds for
asserting with certainty that the divine
or God exists
and Akash Cal is going to say a few
things about this at various points the
other key thing is what we might call
the entire field of ethics philosophy
can put God aside and put any sort of
religious teachings aside and say can we
in fact come to understand what is best
for us solely by looking at our human
nature or looking at the way the
universe seems to be designed or how it
works for other animals or any of those
sorts of things and we're going to come
back to that in just a moment now if we
talk about the god of faith what we will
often call the God of Abraham Isaac and
Jacob the God who is revealed through
these Hebrew Scriptures and practices
and then later for Christians like
Paschal revealed also through the figure
the person of Jesus and the things that
are written about him and then his
ongoing activity of the church this is a
God who is believed in Pascal will
actually draw a distinction between the
philosopher who says I know skiore all
right
skee Oh and in Latin and the believer
who says I believe cradle right we get
the word created from that so believed
in by faith and faith resides it's not a
simply a blind adherence or some sort of
emotional attachment but it resides in
what Paschal calls the heart and it's
worth remembering at this point that
Paschal has that very important
discussion where he says the heart has
its reasons that reason itself does not
know the heart is not merely some sort
of lower emotional animal brain or
something along those lines by
comparison to our much higher cognitive
faculties the heart is actually the core
of the human being as a fully human
being so it's also something that has
its own dignity you might say how does
faith get in the heart this also is a
place where Paschal is going to clarify
God puts it in there it's not something
that you can will or wish your way into
or take a pill and then suddenly you've
got it it's not something purely random
it happens through grace so here we go
beyond the realm of philosophy as such
of course
although philosophy can indeed extend
itself to that point it's not simply
irrational this is why I say that Pascal
is not merely a traditional fetus in one
of the discussions he says the conduct
of God who disposes all things well or
kindly is to put religion into two
places into the mind by reason which
means that rational means could in fact
help to lead to religion but then he
also says into the heart by grace and he
goes on a little bit further this should
there's a good passage to think about so
we'll to put it into the mind and heart
by force and threats is not to put
religion there but rather terror the big
problem in Pascal's on time
and he condemned the attempts to try to
impose religion upon people simply by
force he thought that was a
counterproductive strategy so what else
can we say about this let's go back to
the the proofs of God's existence
Paschal is actually going to tell us
that as he says the metaphysical proofs
of God's existence are not particularly
convincing why is that so they certainly
are convincing for those who accept the
rational principles that those proofs
are based on here's the past that she
says the metaphysical proofs of God are
so remote from the reasoning of men so
remote from most ordinary people's
reasoning and so complicated that they
make little impression and if they
should be of service to some he's not
denying that they are useful for some
people it would only be during the
moment that they see such demonstration
but an hour afterwards they fear they
have been mistaken and this is in fact
the experience of so many people who
encounter arguments or proofs or
whatever you want to call them rational
demonstrations of God's existence they
wrap their head around it for a certain
amount of time they say aha I do see
that that that really does work and then
a little bit later they're like how did
that go again
now why was I saying that it was a good
argument and some himself the originator
of what has come to be called the
ontological argument himself wavered
back and forth on whether the argument
that he was seeking was actually a way
of illuminating his mind or a tool of
the devil for seducing him away from his
proper job so arguments for God's
existence you can't in fact produce them
what they don't really convince people
that long there's another great passage
where Pascal is talking about
making arguments from the order that we
see in in things in in the world and he
tells us that many of these arguments
are not all that convincing either here
we go
says I admire the boldness with which
people undertake to speak of God in
addressing the argument to infidels that
is people who don't believe or believe
the wrong things their first chapters to
prove divinity from the works of nature
and Paschal says I wouldn't be
astonished at their Enterprise if they
are addressing their argument to the
faithful for it's certain that those who
have the notice living faith in their
heart
see all at once that existence is none
other than the work of the God whom they
adore they have no problem making that
connection and seeing that it provides a
certain intelligibility but those in
whom this light is extinguished and in
whom we purpose to rekindle it persons
destitute of faith and grace seeking
with all their light whatever they see
in nature can that can bring them to
this knowledge find only obscurity and
darkness to tell them that they only
have only to look at the smallest things
and they will see God openly to give
them as a complete proof of this great
and important matter the course of the
moons and planets is to give them ground
for believing the proofs of our religion
are very weak so the philosopher thinks
that they're accomplishing something
with these proofs of God's existence and
the philosopher may in fact be
accomplishing something for the
philosopher but the philosophers proofs
for really everybody else are quite weak
as a matter of fact they only really
work when you've already got faith
working for you in which case they're
not exactly proofs are they they're at
best sort of elaborations of the
understanding what about the issue of
morality and happiness again
Pascal has a wonder
full set of discussions about this he
says all human beings seek seek
happiness this is without exception
whatever means they employ they all tend
to this end this is the cause for them
going to war others avoiding it and so
on and so forth he goes on a little bit
further and says yet after such a great
number of years known without faith has
reached the point to which all
continually look a trial so long so
continuous so uniform should certainly
convince us of our inability to reach
the good by our own efforts but example
teaches us little thus well the
president never satisfies this
experience dupes us from misfortune to
misfortune leads us to death their
eternal crown and what is he complaining
about here the philosophers think the
way to happiness is much more
straightforward easy to illuminate path
than is actually the case and that's a
problem once again the Philosopher's you
know may in fact make it easy for
themselves in pursuing God but the God
that they have in mind is a little bit
different than the God of faith and this
is not going to be helpful for most
people another area another passage he
says they believe God alone is worthy to
be loved and admired and they've desired
to be loved and admired of men and don't
know their own corruption and this is
really one of the problems these
philosophers have too great a faith and
I am using that word deliberately here
in the capacities of their own reason
and because of that Paschal thinks they
wind up being sort of inhabited you
might say by a kind of pride a pride
which is going to lead them astray so he
goes on and he and he says this is in
another place the god of Christians is a
God who makes the soul feel that God is
for only good that
her only rest is in him her only delight
is in loving him who makes her at the
same time abhor the obstacles which keep
her back and prevent her from loving God
with all her strength
what are those obstacles he names them
here two of them self love and lust
these are unbearable to her whereas they
may not be to the philosopher the
philosopher thinks that you don't have
to really change yourself in order to
understand God in order to relate
yourself to the divine and a little bit
later on he's going to tell us we know
God only by Jesus Christ so that's a
very strong statement of faith without
this mediator all communion with God has
taken away so he says all those who have
claim to know God and to prove him
without Jesus Christ have only weak
proofs and so what is Christ showing us
what is the upshot of that for paschal
somebody might say all right so you
Christians what do you actually bring to
the table what is the distinctive value
added to use another term well he tells
us in several places what that is she
says the Christian religion teaches
people two truths well these two truths
not exclusively these two trous there is
a God who people human beings can know
and there is a corruption within our
nature which renders us unworthy of that
God and he says it's equally important
to know both of these two points this is
where the philosophers have gone wrong
they understood the one point that we
can in fact come to understand God they
were far too optimistic in their own
capacities to do so because they didn't
take account of the corruption of human
nature he says it's equally dangerous
for man to know God without knowing his
own wretchedness it's also bad to know
your own wretchedness without knowing
the Redeemer who can free you from it
and he says now
if only one of these points gives rise
to the pride of the philosophers who
have known God and not their own
wretchedness or to the despair of
atheists who know their own wretchedness
but not the Redeemer so he says it's
necessary to the human beings to know
these two points it's also merciful of
God to have made us know them and this
is what the Christian religion does so
you might think about the faith that
that Paschal is putting forward as
something different than the pure
rationality of the Philosopher's as
something that doesn't just simply go
against rationality it's not irrational
in some respect
it is super irrational because it
integrates the rational person and their
Faculty of Reason into a fuller
perspective that is going to be not
simply in the mind but also in the heart
this results in a different conception a
fuller richer conception from pas
scholars point of view of God than that
which the Philosopher's can provide
you